CARTER MORGAN: Great news.
Critter Junction's
game just got featured
as game of the century
on every app store.
Let's look at how
Critter Junction
is going to handle all
of this new traffic.
Stay tuned.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Critter Junction has
done a lot of great work
to be scalable, resilient,
and highly available.
But their traffic is set
to increase exponentially,
and they're not sure their
current infrastructure can
meet those needs.
The biggest problem is that
Critter Junction's traffic
has consistent spikes as people
all over the world log on when
they're in the mood to
play with a virtual pet
with their friends.
To accommodate this
traffic, Critter Junction
allocated more resources
but was burning money
during non-busy hours.
Still, that was better
than the alternative--
risking service outages by not
allocating enough resources.
Luckily, when Critter
Junction switched
to a microservice
architecture, they
decided to host their
application on Google
Kubernetes Engine,
and so they got
to use two Kubernetes
features that are designed
to solve exactly this--
horizontal pod and
cluster autoscaling.
In Kubernetes, you can think
of a pod as an application
instance.
It has one or more
containers that
are coupled together
and treated as one unit.
The horizontal pod autoscaler
automatically adds or removes
pods based on the usage
rate of your application.
So if a lot of people are
currently using your app
and its computational needs
go up, it'll add pods for you.
And if that usage rate
drops, then autoscaler
will automatically remove pods.
This happens based on CPU and
memory metrics by default,
but it's also possible
to use custom metrics.
This is great for
handling more requests
when you have enough
space to run more pods on.
But if there's no space to
run additional pods, then
even if the horizontal pod
autoscaler wants to add more,
out of luck, unless you're
using cluster autoscaler.
What this does is it
adds more resources
to your clusters-- in this case,
machines that pods can run on.
We added these features
to Critter Junction's
architecture, which did help
alleviate some of the problems.
But as we researched more, we
realized that in many cases
the application would run out
of memory under a heavy load.
And there wasn't
a really good way
to estimate how much memory
was needed at any given time,
so we took a different approach.
Cluster autoscaler and
horizontal pod autoscaling
are both examples of
horizontal scaling,
or scaling out, which
means they focus
on adding more total
resources for the application
to use as a whole.
But sometimes it's necessary
to scale vertically, or scaling
up, by modifying the
resources provisioned
to an individual service,
like if a pod doesn't
have enough CPU or if
it has too much RAM.
That's where GKE's vertical
pod autoscaler comes in.
Vertical pod autoscaler
exists to automatically set
up-to-date resource limits and
requests for the containers
in their pods.
It can both downscale pods that
are over-requesting resources
and also upscale pods that
are under-requesting resources
based on their usage over time.
This seemed like a good fit
for Critter Junction's problem,
so we helped them enable
the vertical pod autoscaler
on their cluster.
Then, to get a good baseline
for CPU and memory resources,
we used vertical
pod autoscaler's
sizing recommendations by
creating a vertical pod
autoscaler whose update
mode was set to off.
Finally, we updated
the deployment
to account for these
recommendations,
and Critter Junction was able
to run a lot more efficiently.
Guessing what resources
your app needs
is tricky, but by leveraging
horizontal and vertical
autoscaling,
Critter Junction was
able to better manage
their workloads,
become more resilient,
and save money
on over-allocating resources.
All that was left
to do was celebrate
their well-earned traffic boost.
So that's a wrap for this
episode of "Season of Scale."
Stay tuned to learn how
Critter Junction continues
to improve the design of
their app architecture and dev
processes.
And, remember, always
be architecting.
[MUSIC PLAYING]